voici leur venue de regarder ce
reportage de jacky davin que je vous
annonçais tout à l'heure sachez d'abord
que notre propos ici n'est pas de
dénoncer ou de donner des leçons
moins encore de livrer des recettes non
notre propos est simplement de vous
montrer un peu un peu de la réalité de
notre monde dont l'on n'imagine pas
toujours la fragilité
à côté des montagnes de foie gras de
l'huître de saumon de 20 de pâtisserie
il existe et il faut le savoir une marge
douloureuse où la dignité de l'être
humain est atteinte
pour autant pas question de vous donner
mauvaise conscience ce serait facile de
susciter un vague élan qui est
retomberait dès demain matin il faut
simplement que vous regardiez que vous
sachiez la regardons maintenant ce
reportage
[Musique]
si red bull a retiré un conduit de
nourriture pour mes enfants pour moi
quelle est votre situation mais rade
c'est débattent à y travailler non et
tous les jours vous revenez retirer ce
colis oui comment at on décidé de lui
donner ce colis que j'étais dans mon
statut social j'ai dit que j'avais très
peu de ressources que j'aime et ce que
j'avais deux enfants firme a été pour
nous faire le coup le pouvoir magique
mais c'est pour vous les nouveaux
pauvres
la nouvelle pauvreté qu'est ce que ça
veut dire je crois que ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que le ce qui est nouveau
c'est le fait qu'on parle des pauvres
je crois que il ya toujours eu des
pauvres et peut-être site étant habitués
pendant toutes ces décennies
nous nous étions habitués aussi à la
croissance maintenant que la crise est
là que la mutation une société et là on
parle de la pauvreté parce qu'elle
grandit et le fait même d'en parler
peut-être et même certainement suscitera
des solidarités que nous avions
peut-être laissé de côté
madame disons madame x est divorcée elle
a deux enfants à charge
elle travaille à mi temps le revenu
mensuel de la famille et de 3000 francs
vous avez le département j'avais été
apportées n'ont jamais quitté
l'appartement que je gardais j'ai gardé
appartements et mon mari m'a laissé tout
le canada mais il arrive un moment où
comme ce mois ci par exemple si je
voulais un jamais atteint ce crochet de
ne pas payer le loyer
essayez de faire pousser les impôts
locaux
bon j'ai envoyé le chèque de dieppe
parce que j'ai peur que l'on recoupe par
rapport aux chiffres âge
interrogé fait un chèque en blanc nous
respirons mon en fait la situation
bon moi on s'est peut-être pas très très
vous voulez dire oui à plus dramatique
que vous voilà déjà qui est déjà pas mal
de ramadi pourquoi acceptez-vous pas
d'être face à la caméra
parce que on les parents croient que je
me sens qu'un masque et voulait pas être
reconnus chercher du travail à plein
temps
bon j'ai cru en moi dès demain je me
suis mise au chômage pour les après midi
puisque c'est la prime ou vous cédez pas
une question indiscrète que je voudrais
vous poser mais je voudrais vous
demander pourquoi les personnes qui sont
dans votre cas et vous même chercher à
vous retirer de la société ne pas qu'on
sache quelle est votre situation vous
pensez que la société trop cruel pour
comprendre vos problèmes
ce pavé difficile de dire comment que
d'argent semble qu'on se plaint bon
c'est que les gens souffrent plus que
nous qui s'est faite trop délicat
propres expositions à n'importe qui j'ai
rien prémédité voie vers leurs yeux
noirs oui mais des intérêts sont pas
obligés de supporter grâce 15 je demande
pas la charité je ne me mets pas comment
donne quoi que ce soit je veux du
travail pour gagner de l'argent mais
puisqu'on est dans une société où il
faut de l'argent
moi je demande du travail je prenne pas
à noël on voit la lune alors que vos
enfants de l'appareil
et monsieur vous venez de la région
lyonnaise xavier trouver du travail ici
à montpellier il s'avère que ce travail
n'était pas très très fixe puisque vous
n'avait duré qu'un mois et demi
mais ce soir ça fait déjà plus de plus
d'un an que je suis au chômage est bon
il fallait absolument que je voulais
absolument d'en sortir et j'étais un peu
près à gauche alors je me suis lancée
sur dans cet emploi parce que je pensais
que c'était la seule solution pour moi
au moins me lancer dans quelque chose
comme si ça correspondait pas à ce que
j'avais fait deux avants à mes études et
état je pensais que c'était quand même
quelque chose qui pourrait me sortir
momentanément du mauvais pas dans lequel
j'étais puis finalement s'est avéré que
c'était trop difficile et alors
maintenant vous avez de quoi
d'actuellement je n'ai plus rien je n'ai
plus puisque je n'ai plus des jeunes et
pas d'assedic état il ya un travail et
trop peu de temps dans cette entreprise
je vous retrouve de nouveau 100 100
assedic sans aucun retard je suis
actuellement son opération famille vital
à lyon oui ma famille est à lyon et vous
en avez pour combien de temps vous allez
rester ici je reste ici pour l'instant
parce que j'espère que ma femme va
pouvoir rejoindre parce que l'état et de
la région et enfin c'est tout à tout ça
y est totalement aléatoire corps je sais
plus du tout ce que je peux faire
surtout que la balle les problèmes de
chômage sont aussi c'est dur que qui 6 1
vous habitez un appartement vous allez
pouvoir y rester j'habite actuellement 2
un petit à petit et chalon meublé quoi
c'est quelque chose de vraiment minimum
et je pense que à partir du mois
prochain je pourrais pas me marier alors
je sais pas comment j'ai fait je crois
que la mutation de société dans laquelle
que nous affrontons est vraiment
phénomène majeur qui accélère la
descente dans la précarité
en effet le chômage est quelque chose de
d'angoissant pour nous tous et les gens
qui passent le peuvent être affrontés au
chômage
à ce moment là ils connaîtront une
situation difficile c'est ça le
phénomène de cet hiver et nous y pensons
tous à ce niveau il ya deux grandes
causes de pour contrer dans la précarité
et éventuellement d itinérance et je
pense qu'actuellement ces fins de droit
ces gens qui sont au chômage présente à
l'état de précarité tels que leur
structure familiale et plates que leurs
points de repères ne sont plus ce qu'ils
sont qui sont obligés de de se mettre
hors du circuit de leurs réseaux
habituels
et puis il y à l'autre cause de la
précarité c'est ce sont les jeunes les
jeunes qui ne rentrent pas dans notre
société et qui sont en pleine itinérance
nous pouvons dire que il ya dans
certaines de nos
des centaines de familles qui vivent
avec 20 francs de moins par tête
d'habitant que le minimum vieillesse
alors quand on pense que le minimum
vieillesse était je souhaitais pour nous
une référence là la somme la moins
importante que l'on pour survie pour
survivre maintenant
nous disons qu'il ya énormément de gens
des familles des enfants qui vivent avec
beaucoup moins et cela c'est un autre
parent et c'est ce qui motive
vraisemblablement les soucis des
pouvoirs publics de nous voir nous
mobiliser les uns les autres pour
essayer d'améliorer cette situation
nous allons essayer de vous accueillir
notre mot certes ils pourront faire le
non c'est pas vrai c'est qu'on souhaite
c'est le tout ça va être de pouvoir pour
nous placer à côté des autres puisque
nous sommes nous dépassons le new
nombreux qui est admis ici mais nous
allons essayer de nous débrouiller
procédure si vous êtes confrontés tous
les soirs avec ce problème d'accueil
visiblement ce centre est saturé alors
qu'on menait actuellement combien de
gens cherchent de quoi voir un abri le
soir dans une grande ville si la venue
de montpellier les statistiques du coi
200 personnes à peu près qui tous les
soirs sont sans abri c'est pourquoi
après la circulaire de l'aujourd'hui
d'un dut fois que nous avons plus
construire et c'est en cours de
construction un accueil de 30 lits
supplémentaires
nous espérons que ce sera notre cadeau
aux personnes sans abri pour noël par
ailleurs ce centre et fonctions à
complet nous avons trois appartements
pour des mères avec enfants mais sur ce
n'est pas suffisant nous continuons pour
en avoir d'autres aujourd'hui
travaillent en fait ni plus ni moins et
je suis venue cet été y sont obligés de
travailler sur montpellier ont su
remonter un peu dans le nord et je bois
trop de boulot aussi loin en descendant
et si j'aurai plus de chance de trouver
d'où s'échappent travaillé cet été
en fait il s'avère que bon bah on peut
lier aérien quoi y'a rien de local est
la situation actuellement ben moi si tu
vois si vous avez quel âge
moi j'ai 30 ans et quelle est votre
situation actuellement situé à ce soir
ce soir je suis hébergé ici dans ce
foyer tous les matins vers 6h pour le
boulot j'ai pas un centime ce qui
s'appelle un centime bon pour manger etc
je me débrouille et que la soupe
populaire son appellation populaire les
matins je me lève à 6h le matin suisse
est votre intérêt je veux aller regarder
les annonces qui pourraient intéresser
bon
les pende moi j'ai rien trouvé quoi je
veux dire de toutes les boîtes d'intérim
à chaque fois ses moyens de nous alors
j'y passe 400 fois dans la journée
prendra personnellement je sais j'en ai
marre que l'association que touché par
préval c'est le seul truc que je demande
c'est d'avoir le droit au travail et de
pouvoir bosser de m'installer d'avoir un
appartement et c'est heureux de vivre
normalement sans la peine normalement
[Musique]
monsieur l'année leur déchéance peut-on
dire que c'est lorsque l'on perd son
foyer lorsque l'on perd son appartement
les deux ces combinés parce que la perte
de l'appartement est la conséquence
souvent de la perte de l'emploi il n'y a
pas d'issue et lorsqu'il n'y a plus de
quoi nourrir les enfants de plus de quoi
payer une loi le le logement c'est la
famille qui se dispersent
c'est l'effondrement surtout lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de familles aux toulousains et
vous vivez vous à longueur de journée
ses bras c'est sans arrêt sasin délégué
régional
de là ces jeunes n'est pas même sens si
tu es je vais vous citer un exemple
terrible je vous dirai pas où mais le
fait on nous a prévenus à temps il a
fallu enfoncer la porte
le père la mère et les trois enfants on
avait ouvert le gaz en grand et rap à
une pompe qui ne ne paraîtra pas dans la
presse mais c'était la dernière
extrémité
arrivés en fin de droits de chômage plus
rien avec 200 francs par julie par mois
on est le fait on ne peut pas donner à
manger aux enfants
on a vu cette personne qui cherche du
travail mais qui visiblement de plus en
plus n'a même plus de quoi se vêtir
correctement c'est aussi cet homme c'est
un des problèmes les plus graves
parce que la dégradation de l'individu
ne passe pas seulement par la perte de
lampaul le placard du logement
la conséquence c'est que lorsqu'on ne
peut plus coucher d'une façon normale
lorsqu'on a plus le choix
les vêtements ne peut plus nettoyées on
ne peut plus avoir de l'ange on ne peut
plus lui même être présentable pour se
présenter chez son employeur aussi d'
aventure ont trouvé un emploi
[Musique]
les produits alimentaires que vous voyez
déchargée par ces militaires sont des
produits qui normalement aurait dû aller
à la décharge carrés musulmans dans le
cliché populaire du monde france dans un
pays où il y as production et même
surproduction dans un pays où l'on jette
à la décharge où l'on recouvre de mazout
beaucoup de produits alimentaires qui
peuvent être consommés par l'homme
pourquoi certains n'ont même pas de quoi
manger à midi et le soir pourquoi
certains enfants n'ont même pas de quoi
manger une simple purée de pommes de
terriens tous les pas si simple et c'est
vrai qu'au delà de cette image lorsque
l'on se penche sur ce problème
alors là on commence à voir les vraies
difficultés car ces produits qui sont là
si on veut les récupérer
premièrement où les stocker deuxièmement
il faut des chambres froides
deuxièmement qui va les distribuer il
faut des camions il faut des volontaires
pour y distribuer faut toute une
organisation
alors cette année en fin de l'année on a
pris des mesures on a débloqué une
certaine somme d'argent pour que ces
produits alimentaires lie plus à la
décharge
à partir de là il a fallu organiser
toute cette de chêne chambre froide
sur l'a64
young de centre droite a été mené pour
que les associations stocks qui s'est
produit il faut ensuite des camions
alors là plusieurs cas soit des camions
militaires soit même dans certaines
communes ici nous avons derrière nous la
ville de lodève qui a envoyé un camion
et ensuite eh bien il faut des
volontaires pour distribuer tous ces
produits et monsieur agences et emmaüs
qui a été chargé par toutes les
associations et également par toutes les
collectivités pour rassembler tous ces
produits alimentaires et les distribue
alors dans la pratique comment cela se
passe-t-il
mais tout simplement nous avons pensé
qu'il était très difficile pour le
bureau d'aidé sociale de stocker des
camions de 30 tonnes ainsi que pour les
associations dont nous avons demandé à
la sica de nous louer une chambre froide
location au prix coûtant et nous
stockons et nous répartissions tous les
vendredis matins nous répartissions dans
différentes villes de me de l'hérault
alors les personnes qui se présentent
ont une carte est ce que ces cartes ne
rappelle pas de tristes souvenirs
non parce qu' on essaie de faire ça dans
ce sens que ça se sache trop les repas
sont servis à l'intérieur et les colis
seront distribués dans plusieurs centres
façon que les familles en difficultés ne
sont pas au vu de tout le monde
[Musique]
il
voilà vous êtes assistante sociale c'est
à dire que vous êtes sur le terrain
alors prenons un exemple aujourd'hui
quel est votre travail
aujourd'hui j'ai permanence toute la
matinée
donc je reçois un certain nombre de
personnes à ma permanence
ce sont des personnes qui
ont des problèmes de dents payer de
loyer d'impayés d'électricité des
personnes qui sont demandeurs d'emploi
non secouru pour lesquelles nous sommes
obligés de faire nous essayons de paille
est pas lié à leurs difficultés
nous leur redonnant des noues leur
distribuant des colis alimentaires aux
personnes qui viennent vous voir vivent
avec quel salaire mensuel nous recevons
des personnes qui n'auront rien du tout
nous avons l'impression de tenir à bout
de bras des gens qui sont vraiment dans
la détresse
maintenant des chômeurs de
professionnels je pense qu'il en a
toujours existé et qu il en existera
toujours mais enfin si ce n'est pas
cette catégorie de personnes que nous
recevons et ce n'est pas la catégorie la
plus importante je pense elle nous avons
vraiment le sentiment de porter à bout
de bras certaines personnes qui sont
vraiment totalement démunis monsieur
nous venons de quitter ce bureau d'être
social où il ya une permanence qui est
assurée tous les jours matin et soir
pour accueillir ces personnes dans la
détresse ces personnes vraiment qu'ils
ont besoin
dieu d'un colis de nourriture mais pour
vous les associations qui allez vous
lancer dans cet accueil pour distribuer
les colis est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
problème de permanence il est certain
que nous autres pour notre association
nous aurons des besoins de bénévoles de
bénévoles pour assurer les mêmes
permanence que font le bureau dette
sociale c'est à dire une permanence de
tous les jours il est vrai que le
secours catholique le secours populaire
qui vont assurer la distribution se
ressemblent de la ville ont déjà une
longue tradition de distribution et ce
qui manquera ce sont les bénévoles pour
assurer cette permanence je crois que
c'est vrai et c'est peut-être le lieu
dire ici qu'il faut venir conforter nous
voulons toutes les bonnes volontés
seront bien accueillis pour faire du
bénévolat
vous l'avez dit mieux que moi monsieur
davin mais c'est vrai c'est un appel
qu'on peut lancer ici à montpellier
je pense d'ailleurs dans la région dans
tout dans toutes les villes qui vont
comme on l'a vu distribuer à dos si
cette nourriture aux plus déshérités
voilà nous venons de recevoir un coup de
téléphone il faut quand même que je vous
le signale la jeune femme que vous avez
vu au début de ce reportage de dos elle
qui a deux enfants et bien la société g
le bond de montpellier son directeur
viennent au téléphone et lui offre un
emploi
ce n'était pas l'objet de cette émission
mais qu'elle en soit remerciée en son
nom
[Musique]